[Music]  well we know the pandemic has affected  many industries but did you know one of  the hardest hit  are dry cleaners the dry cleaner the dry  cleaning and laundry institute believes  30 percent  of dry cleaners could be forced to shut  down over the next  18 months that's because americans  working from home in casual wear no  longer need to dry clean their workloads  and there are fewer parties weddings and  other occasions to dress up  those who remain open are just trying to  adjust many of them now offering new  services like alterations  and wash and fold for families because  households are chaotic now  with homeschooling and working from home  and things that you didn't have to do  before  well one business also adapting by using  technology customers can pay online  and get a touchless pickup the company  also offering  another incentive same day delivery dry  cleaning hopes the vaccine means there  are brighter days ahead